[Music]
hi
okay my name is nakatovic i'm from tel
aviv israel and whoa a lot of israel is
here today
yeah
and where is my clicker okay
so
i like to start by introducing you to
kinore
kinor is a cool cybersecurity startup
that raises a 10 million precedent round
they have three superstars software
engineer
and a great product manager and they
develop the best code and best software
you can think of
they have perfect instance
infrastructure excellency icd
high scale performance and outstanding
testing mechanism
but despite all of that
they failed
terribly
16 months of developing and writing this
perfect code i just described
was a waste
once they bought it to customers and the
market
no one used it
and
sorry
you see the unfortunate reality is that
great code does not equal a great
product
in order to turn that
statement into a true one
we can use a framework
it's a methodology that i use before i
design and develop
and it can help any an engineering team
to create excellent product
and today i'm going to share this
framework with you and i actually
learned it from my role as a product
manager
so in fact i started to develop when i
was 10
writing my first lines of code in html
i loved it and decided to learn computer
science during high school and then kept
developing for more than 10 years
and i worked with almost any kind of
coding language that you can think of
including javascript and i had the
privilege to explore all aspects of the
engineering stack
back-end front-end android and ios so
essentially
most of my career and most of my life
really i've been working with code
in the last four years i shifted to
product management and now i work at
fiverr a freelancer's marketplace for
digital services
and um
actually um ah okay sorry i'm the
product manager of fibrous communication
it's uh the inbox that i that enables
buyers and sellers to talk and set
expectations
and our notification emails and
collaboration tool
now working as a product manager kind of
changed the way i look at engineering
engineers have a huge part in the
success of the product
they are the inventors designers and
creators
they get a set of requirements and
restrictions like cost security and
scale
and need to build the best solution that
should fit another set of existing
limitations like performance and
backward compatibility
now as a software engineer every time i
got a new task i find myself immediately
starting to think about the solution
jumping straight to what should be the
architecture where is the problem in
that bug and when can i start to
implement
i want to finish all my tasks as soon as
i could and i was running to how the
future should work on the system level
rather than the product level
i always thought about creating the
great the best code and best
functionality but i found out that great
code does not mean a great product
and
now i better understand
that our goals engineers product
analyst we are all part of the same
company that has a business to develop
our goal is the same goal
to create something that people will
want to use and hopefully to pay for
our users i'm sorry to tell you they
don't care about the code what they want
is to have a solution to their problems
so let's dive into this four questions
model it's a methodology that i use
before i design and develop
and
these questions are often raised by
product managers but i found that asking
them as an engineers will help us to
make better engineering decisions and
create better product
and also despite of creating better
product i found it also improve me as
engineer
so
ready
the first question i always start with
is
who is it for and what is the need
so this question is the foundation of
our work we have a new feature to code
right now now what
so first we want to understand who is
our target audience
is it an internal user from our
organization is it our customers why do
they need it and how do they currently
use our product
uh someone is going to use this feature
that we are going to develop so we want
to understand who he or she is
now product managers sometimes call it
persona an imaginary character that
represents a user that uses our product
the persona allows us as developers to
get more
empathy towards the user and to better
understand his behavior
rather than applying our mental models
that often do not reflect the customer
and his needs
now
and sometimes as developers as we mostly
focus on the technical details or on
stuff we should think would be just cool
to implement so we might unintentionally
filter out features that our users may
actually care about
so if we learn who are our users and
what is their needs we'll can we can
make better engineering decision
now at fiverr as example as we are a
marketplace
we have two types of user we have buyers
who comes to fiverr to buy digital
services like good
like logo design
or a
website development and we have the
sellers who offer those services
now recently we've changed the first
experience when buyers interacting with
sellers for the first time
so when a buyer comes to fiverr he is
looking for something he would like to
order a service
and
um
[Music]
he has a dedicated page for that as you
can see
and if he wants to contact the seller to
get more information and to
expectations so he can ask the seller a
question
now we change this model from this
to this as you can see on the left and
we improved the experience at least in
my opinion and we've added some
structure messages and also this
emoji component
that allows the buyers to
add emojis when clicked so you can
express his need better
now if we think of our buyer for a
moment or persona
it's someone wants to contact the
business to get more information on what
you would like to order and to express
what he wants
and
the emojis are nice and great and fun
but if we think of it no not everyone is
going to use them
so what our developers decided to do
is to implement this emoji component
with lazy load
so we want to slow down the loading of
this page and detract from the
experience so this is one decision we
could make because we understand who is
our users now what's up or slack as
example
could not implement it like that because
emojis are used more frequently so we
always want to know who is our user and
their needs
and this thinking allow us to
think of more of other edge cases like
errors launch inputs
or the need for an empty state
and
different solutions are available for
different use cases and each solution
will affect
our implementation and the architecture
that will build
with this we can go to the next question
what does success look like or in other
words what is the goal
now personally i think
that coding is awesome
i love to code i can code because it's
fun or i want to acquire
learn new technology and acquire
experience
thank you
but when i code for a company i work for
i want to consider the big picture and
the overall goal
now success means different things to
different people right
as a developer i used to think of
success as code with zero bugs that is
easy to maintain
and sometimes i would even measure the
number of lines of code i've deleted
now i'm not saying it's not important
but it's not the only thing that matters
because in reality
this perfect code i wrote might have
zero value to the user and product
so to understand what is success i
invite you to consider two main
components our business goal and our
feature goal
to understand the feature goal we should
we want to understand what our company
does ourselves
what is the business model and what is
the purpose of our product
now and if there's something that our
company is focused on right now and
consider a success right now we also
want to know what is that
so i want to ask you a question how many
of you here raise your hand by raising
your hand if you know what what the main
goal or main metric that your company is
measuring
okay a few of you
nice not a lot so why am i asking
it's important to know that
so
today it's really important like all the
best and successful companies are
product oriented it means that everyone
at the company knows what are the goals
and metrics are and
the
if you don't know
i kind of suggest to go back to your
managers and ask it's really important
it's really changed how i look at things
and going to when i'm going to develop a
new feature
now
also in today's world the best engineer
is no longer the one with the best
knowledge of technology stack it's the
one who understand the problem the
business and the big picture and as
developers who understand that we can
give a lot more value to our companies
so
we want to understand the business goal
and keep that in mind but also we have
the feature goal
the feature goal is what we're trying to
do with this new feature that we are
adding what we're what we're trying to
achieve
it could be user acquisition or
generating more cells
it could be uh the importance of
performance or
running in real time so we want to
understand what is our goal of the
future that we are adding
with that we want to measure
how we want to understand how we as
developers could make an impact could
make a difference with this feature
as we don't want to waste time on
improving the load of a page that is
barely used right no one likes to do
that
so
we will
to understand how it will help us to
make better engineering decision
uh let's see an example from fiverr so
on fiverr we said that we succeed when
our buyers and sellers succeed
and if we think again about the first
interaction between buyers and sellers
that we discussed on the last question
what does success look like for this
feature
so
our goal then is to create more new
meaningful conversation that will
benefit our users
now
as a reminder we did this change from
what you can see on the left or what you
can see on the right
now let's assume for this example that
we increased the loading time of this
model of this model by 400 milliseconds
so what do you think after this change
should we keep this change or revert it
is it a good change or a bad one if
there's a delay now
so any idea no
so
what we should do here to understand if
we want to keep this change or not is to
go back to our goal
and ask
after this change are we
do we have more meaningful conversations
and do we have now more successful
buyers and sellers now yes we need to
define what is meaningful conversation
and what is success but we'll keep this
for another talk
but
we'll go back to this uh to this goal
and we'll see if we did a good impact
and if yes if we did
a good impact we're moving towards our
goal
and we will keep this change obviously
now another benefit of keeping the goal
in mind is that it allow us to talk
about the business more and understand
and speak the business language and with
that we can give more valuable insight
to the discussion
um let's think we are working on
a new feature and we know we are certain
there's a big technical change
refactoring that we need to do
so instead of trying to convince our
stakeholders that we want to do that
by using buzzwords like spaghetti code
or technical depth we can also speak
their business language and say that if
we want to do this refactoring our
development time is going to increase by
every time we'll add a new functionality
to a page
if we'll speak the business language
i'll bet now that your stakeholders will
consider this change
trust me i'm a product manager
so
um learning this language enables us to
more effectively communicate about what
else is needed and take more
um
decision about our product
so and it's not always about finding the
best
it's about it's not always about our
solution it's about finding the best
solution
and sometimes we can arrive at that
until some conversations and compromises
so remember
we want to keep the goal in mind so we
can
bring more valuable insight to the
discussion and take the right decision
for the product
for the third question
what is the minimum value i can
deliver so one of our biggest concerns
when it comes to launching a new product
is whether our users is going to use it
product or feature
and
here comes the concept i'm sure you
already heard of the mvp
minimum viable product
the idea of the mvp is to introduce to
our users minimal functionality as
quickly as possible to get feedback and
learn if it's something that we want to
keep or not
and if not we'll change
so
mvp development is about releasing small
featured features
each time step by step so we can focus
on one thing at a time and and gather
data the product manager will get data
on user behavior and we can get
technical data like performance traffic
scale bugs so
we will do we will develop
step by step and then we will learn from
that now the minimally viable does not
mean
perfect
we want to get to perfect but we have a
long growth
we should not try to achieve perfect
code or feature on our first iteration
i know it's hard we always want our code
to be superb
but that's why the mvp is all about
gathering the maximum knowledge through
the minimal feature set
and to prove or disprove the assumption
that we made while designing now
we will
um imagine our best solution
and it's okay if on the first phase we
won't think about all aspects we won't
consider
extra storage or limitation we will
imagine the best solution and then we'll
ask
is this idea is technically doable
what do we need in order to make it work
do we have the resources for that will
it work at scale
and if not
what will be the smallest piece of code
or functionality that will give us value
and enables us to learn if it if we want
to invest more time with this and then
to add these new uh
resources and
new storage
so
we will build the first minimum step we
will measure
our change and we will evaluate if it's
something we want to keep or not
maybe on the first phase we will code
something only for ios because most of
our users are there
and
maybe we can use an existing design
library because
we have some functionality that exists
and we don't want to develop it from
scratch
so we will build that we will measure
and evaluate if we want to invest more
or not
now time to deliver is also a parameter
here a good delivery or feature is
measured by value divided by time
if the best feature ever will take three
months to develop a company may not gain
any value from that because
one of the competitors could release
smaller functionality
more quickly and
still they're
still their customers
so it's always a matter of both time and
value
the thinking allows us to better
understand what what we want
how do we want to keep
developing and we want to deliver in
small pieces so
we can make better product decisions and
better engineering decisions
moving on to our last question
what else
so
this question is my favorite one
and i find it useful not only at work i
use it all the time and i think it's the
most meaningful question
one can ask
now this is the our time to think
outside the box and ask
what else
what else i should know or what else can
i do to improve
it's an opportunity for the product
manager to mention anything that's
important to them
and we're totally going to get more
context of what we're doing and maybe we
will hear about a quick win we can
implement easily
and what else did we cover all the use
cases and what happened if we have more
can we add them easily
many edge cases are technical and won't
be endorsed by the product manager it
could be broken apis insufficient cpu or
others
so
what else is a great
place to take space and think
it enables it
drives creativity and enables us to
think about all aspects and see if
something is missing
um this is the final step
when on asking all the questions
and put all the pieces of the puzzles
together
and what else
so what we need is to ask
if we'll cover all these questions that
that we just spoke about if we know how
to answer them um
we we're definitely going to have more
follow-up questions as well
so ask
the product manager might not mention
something because for them is obvious or
we might not
or we might not have all the answers
but if we ask the right questions we
also might come up with a better simple
solution
something that if we wouldn't think of
if we wouldn't ask now programming
is more than just typing code
it's the art of solving complex problems
building something from scratch and
thinking about all aspects
great code can absolutely be a great
product we just need to ask the right
question and use this framework
so if we'll ask who is it for and what
is the need
what does success look like what is the
minimum value i can deliver and what
else
we asking this question is a proven
clearer way to get the full picture of
what we are doing
and together engineers
and product managers we will build
better software better code and
obviously better products to our users
thank you